moving into a house built in the 1920s I
wasn't surprised that there were
lingering Spirits here but honestly it's
just like having very elusive oh the
door you see the door shut in the
background
there's no other way it could happen
than a ghost how what other Force could
shut a door never mind that you could
see a person moving in the background to
shut the door they always do things that
like anyone
could do
they're ghosts they have supernatural
abilities they should be able to do
things on camera that could never be
duplicated by anyone at least without
the access to Hollywood level special
effects
ghosts could do that if they existed and
yet they never do
ever all that goes ever do is just like
shut a door or drop a spoon